and you know i i'm not gonna claim that
i had some sort of
foreboding or gut feeling but
the steelers have played poorly
and for the bengals we've talked about
this dynamic in the past texans on
thanksgiving this is it this is their
super bowl this is their playoff game
this is the last time anybody is going
to give a crap about the bengals until
2021 september so go out and
shoot your shot and play your game and
hope for the best and
it worked the steelers stink the bengals
pulled it together for one night and now
things are extremely
interesting man
in the afc north by the way good morning
it's pft live on peacock series xm211
nbcsn
sky sports nfl 7 pm prime time for our
friends in the uk ireland podcast
whenever wherever however good morning
chris it was a halloween game i was
entertained i was that's all i'm looking
for i just want to be entertained when i
watch a football game and i was
entertained well you're you're
entertained especially when you just
think that one team is going to
you know control the other team
throughout and then the game starts and
you go whoa this doesn't look like
like what i expected and then as it
continues to play
the team that you thought was going to
be dominant is was really getting
dominated in a lot of areas and
certainly couldn't get anything going or
like what we expected to see steelers
are reeling right now i i mean there's
no other way to say it obviously playing
bad football yes teams have figured out
how to play against them in general i
don't think we've ever seen big ben go
through a funk the way
which he is going through here the last
few weeks i mean the first half of the
game last night
not only the interceptions and
everything the interception and
everything like that but just the the
missed receivers and some of the replays
and things like that the juju smith
shuster fumble
chase claypool is running behind him
uncovered no nobody there it's just that
right now where you're not used to
seeing the steelers defense kind of get
bullied a little bit and then of course
big ben and the offense are just totally
off kilter
and more than one or two hospital balls
thrown by ben last night eric ebron got
injured juju smith schuster got blown up
on that one play although he did get
three steps down he did complete the act
of catching the pass and there was a
question about whether or not there was
an illegal hit on defenseless receiver
the way the nfl has explained in the
past if you've had the ball long enough
for it to be a catch
it's you're no longer defenseless and
you can be hit the way he was hit
there's a question though in my mind was
they were lowering the helmet foul right
that was just never discussed the hit
was so violent and the controversy over
whether or not there was a fumble that
kind of took over any other questions
about whether the hit was illegal but it
was a huge hit we'll be talking about
that coming up and you know chris i want
to go to the very beginning look at the
end of the first quarter what was the
score it was three nothing why because
the bengals took a field goal instead of
being quote unquote aggressive oh points
while you can right right yeah we had
this conversation yesterday this is not
the chiefs you you have no mandate to
score touchdowns just start the process
and you can start very simply with three
points on the board and then the next
thing you know it's 10 and then the next
thing you know it's 17 and uh and and
look it wasn't over i thought the
steelers are going to come back and win
the game i got to give the bengals
credit for playing the full 60 minutes
yeah never giving up with nothing to
play for other than pride and sometimes
pride is just enough especially if you
throw on top of it a little dash of yes
we don't like it juju that you come out
and dance on our logo it's a simple
concept we talked about it last week and
you kind of took juju's shots i did of
it i did
look why give the other team anything
that they can point to
as extra motivation and von bell said
during the week we've got to deal with
it between the lines we've got to knock
him down when he has the ball and they
did von bell the guy who said it is the
guy who gave
the tick tock stars account called the
big hit right i mean
one okay
i love it all of it i love that he
danced on the damn emblem again and i
love that it pisses the bangles off it
just makes for a better tv so you know
i'm not that disappointed about it i'm
hoping he goes out as fans still as fans
have to be over it no they have to do it
i would think the team itself is going
to be over it too now there's just been
too much light shed on it now to where
it's become a thing i mean there's no
doubt about it everybody was waiting for
it i was waiting for it last night
watching the pre-game show just sitting
there going is he going to do it again i
think he will i think he's going to do
it one more week because they're going
to feel like they're going to beat the
bengals and he's going to go i've been
doing it all year and blah blah blah
that's kind of been their defense but
i mean i'm with you mike it's gotten to
the point now where it is a thing and
i'll tell you elsewhere it's a thing
after he got hit and fumbled he is i re
i rewound this when i was you know
watching on tv of course
uh he was sitting there talking to james
washington and i swear he was going i
bet you they're gonna blame my fumble on
the dance he said something dance but
either way it's become a distraction
it's become a thing and teams are you
know out for him because of it and
you're right you don't you don't need it
so he's going to have to reevaluate his
next stance for next week
well and matt casey who from time to
time plays the role of cyrano de
bergerac has planted an idea in my brain
what that is a good one and i'm going to
steal it but give him appropriate credit
it allowed the bengals to do to the
steelers what the steelers always do to
the bengals be more physical have that
extra motivation that edge that in your
face we're going to come get you see
wherever you get it from you get it and
juju gave it to the bengals and he gave
it to the bills it wasn't as big of a
deal in the buffalo game because
we kind of expected the bills to win the
game based upon the trajectory the bills
have been on and the trajectory the
steelers had started on we didn't expect
this it's easier to point to this one
and say the steelers are clearly the
better team but you throw that extra
little bit of something
on the bengals and the bengals come out
and do to the steelers with the steelers
due to the bengals that is all the more
reason for mike tomlin to go to juju's
miss shuster and say
stop it just stop it and yeah i can't
wait to see if the steelers lose this
week to the colts if the browns beat the
jets if week 17 is for all the afc north
marbles and they're playing in cleveland
on sunday night football because that
would surely be the game the nfl chooses
to move to prime time because it's the
afc north championship is juju going to
dance on the logo in cleveland i don't
think he will chris
i i don't think he will either i i think
with the way their team is playing
and the spotlight being on them in this
situation
and you know the teams are tweeting
about it players are making comments all
week that that will go away or at least
that he'll dance somewhere else at least
at the very least i think that's what
happens but hey the dealer's got you
know and i thought the same thing like
they'll do it in the locker room or do
it in the parking lot do it but what
what's the what
yeah i don't know you're right there is
no am i missing something are we just
old men yelling at clouds what's the
point no the point is we live in a world
where a lot of people live for their
social media following and likes and all
that crap so that's the point and that's
where he's become you know
second famous as compared to his first
famous job you know in football but he's
he's a social media star and i mean
that's what he has done you know it's
really where he's carved a name for
himself and like the people who don't
pay attention like real closely to
football a lot of them know juju just
through you know tick tock videos and
everything like that him playing online
fortnite and doing that it's part of
kind of his brand so that's why he does
it but it needs to end because it's
affecting the bigger brand which is the
pittsburgh steelers and they just don't
need it right now because they get
enough issues they're not playing good
football on either side of the ball you
know like you said there's the bangles
and you're going oh pittsburgh's going
to come back pittsburgh's going to come
back oh pittsburgh goes down and scores
a touchdown didn't you think when it was
1710 you were like here come the
steelers there's no way
right but they're gonna go they're gonna
stop and they're gonna score another
touchdown you're going okay it's gonna
be a game whatever but then the steelers
defense breaks and lets the bengals
drive down the field and ryan finley
makes a few nice runs and they run the
ball and do all that to where that was
disappointing too in a moment where the
defense had to rise up
they let the team down too so they are
being affected on both sides of the
football right now and just the
inability to make plays and and dominate
the way we kind of saw them dominate the
first 10 11 weeks of the year
mike tomlin has been very entertaining
in his press conferences this year not
that he intends to be let's have a
listen at what he had to say after last
night's 27 to 17 loss
we're not a good football group right
now and um and so
we understand the consequences that come
with that we're working on a short week
we got to be better than what we've been
and um and that's just the reality of it
what's your sense uh regarding your
team's confidence level and uh are you
concerned it's getting a little fragile
should we better not be confident after
after performance like that
no he's right about that but he did add
that he believes that they can fix it
for all of the negativity that resonated
through his comments last night he
believes they can fix it i don't know
that anyone else believes they can fix
it and it's funny chris when they barely
beat the ravens he was upset very upset
that was the us sucking press conference
video then when they lost to washington
and we had this conversation two weeks
ago he actually seemed to me to be
relieved by what it transpired it took
the pressure off of a team that had been
11-0 last night he's resigned to the
fact that right now they are not good
enough they are limping into the final
two weeks of the season they have a
short week now to get ready for the
colts who are 10 and 4 and trying to
nail down their playoff birth
potentially win their division this is
not going to be an easy one on sunday
for the steelers and it does set up
drama in week 17 and sorry steelers fans
yeah i want the colts to win because i
want that week 17 browns and steelers
for all the marbles in the afc north who
wouldn't want that well of course and
mike let me let me ask you this because
i'm trying to figure this out on the fly
but of like the steelers lost to the the
colts this weekend which right now
you're right it's looking like they
probably will
then okay cleveland for the big showdown
in week 17.
is there a chance there's a chance they
could end up playing each other the very
next week in the 4-5 matchup i believe
and play each other two weeks in a row
it could really unfold that way to where
we get some great drama in the afc north
there uh i don't know what the
tiebreaker would be with the colts if
they were tied with one of those teams
but no they wouldn't be yes oh so i mean
yeah that would be that would be
interesting that would be good drama
cleveland cleveland beat the titans and
cleveland beat the colts so if the
browns had the same record as the as
they'll be up there and the browns would
be the three seed they'd be the three
seed the question is that's right
yeah this it could it could end up four
five three six one of those two that
could be the match that's what it is it
could be three six
it could be that that would that would
be interesting sorry to get you off
topic there no it's okay and it would be
the two teams in the same stadium in
consecutive weeks and i think we've seen
that before not a lot of times but we've
seen that repeat of week 17 into the
wild card round but it would be
something if these two teams got
together in the playoffs and as brown's
fans know all too well 38-32 was the
score in 2002
in the postseason the only time this
iteration of the browns franchise made
it to the playoffs they went to the
steelers and kelly holcomb was the star
that day for pittsburgh as they took
down the browns in pittsburgh maybe they
get a rematch in cleveland that would be
a great way for brown's fans to be
amazed to start this
revival right and to get things and you
can't even call it a revival because
they've never there this goes back to 86
87 type stuff for browns fans and that
team is now the ravens i'm sorry folks
that's just the truth but this is an
awesome time for the cleveland browns
and you see the steelers fading yeah
they could fade right out of the
division title and right into that sixth
spot and the browns could end up in the
three spot um have you had a bet right
now what would you bet i mean i mean it
to me
there's a lot to be done here as far as
them you know stopping the the fading i
i'm i'm concerned with them like legit
now how can you not be you know it's
three weeks in a row where you know we
haven't seen the defense really make any
game changing plays like the no bud
dupree no devin bush is you know the
back up to devin bush bullane he's hurt
we're starting to see the effects of
like no play making there right mike
teams have realized too
with the fact that the steelers offense
isn't that good that hey we can play
really conservative on our offensive
side of the ball you know you you think
about teams as you watch filming the
steelers all year the first few weeks of
the year you just go hey we're gonna run
our offense you're gonna run our offense
and then five or six games go by and you
get film on them and you start to break
them down you gotta play them you go
whoa
we gotta like we gotta bring it back a
little bit we can't run our normal d
offense or they're gonna cause turnovers
and get short fields and leave their
offense in all these good spots so teams
have realized hey we can play
conservative and not let their defense
win the game and set their offense up
because hey their offense struggles so
we can get in one of these like tough
defensive battles with the steelers and
feel pretty comfortable about it and
we're seeing teams are kind of beating
them at their own game really here as of
late playing defensive low scoring
football and and finding ways to beat
them
and they're just caught in this
quicksand that they can't get out of i
remember saying
after
because it was the browns who came to
town and it was a blowout win over
cleveland and i picked the browns to win
and when the bengals and joe burrow back
when he was playing and he was healthy
came to town i picked the bengals to
beat the steelers and after that one i
resolved to never pick against the
steelers again at least until they lost
i'm not sure i said that at the time but
i reserved the right to adopt that and
i'm not picking them to win until they
show me that they can win and this is
look hey
this is the perfect opportunity for them
to dig deep maybe when you start 11-0
you need to be hit in the mouth three
different times before you dig deep i
just don't know that will alone is going
to be enough when you look at the
quality of the team right now especially
the questions about ben roethlisberger
let's hear from him what's on the talon
mike tomlin talking about whether to
what extent big ben currently is injured
here they are
i would say that the
i'm not consistent enough
which affects the offense because the
ball is in mind every play
what is the level of uh frustration and
concern right now as you head in the
last two weeks
hi
do you right now in the month of
december truly feel 100 in your arm
well i don't think anybody uh that plays
this game
uh in at any level um you know at any
position i should say uh whether it's
week one or week 16 feels 100 so
no i would say that i don't feel 100 but
nobody does right now your evaluation
just of ben's performance uh he keeps
missing is it an injury what's happening
with him right now
no it's not injury related it just
wasn't good enough like like all of us
me included you know we we got to be
better
there's a vague sense out there that ben
has some sort of a knee injury there was
a report from cbs sports nine days ago
that the steelers are seriously
concerned about roethlisberger's knee
that it's an issue in practicing games
he hasn't been on the injury report for
the last two weeks though with anything
other than getting his usual wednesday
off right for not injury related reasons
and then he says he's not 100 and no one
is well okay no one's 100 but the
question is if you're getting any type
of
treatment for an injury you end up on
the injury report that's the way it
works they have records of that and
that's how the jets got into trouble
back in 2009 because brett favre kept
talking about why he stunk down the
stretch in 2008 after they were and
three and on track to be the one seed
well we had the partially torn biceps
tendon he was getting treatment for it
and the jets got whacked eric mangini
got whacked mike tannebaum got whacked
all because brett favre was talking
about it so presumably there's nothing
that ben is being treated for so yeah
you're not 100 you're banged up you're
sore but that's different from being
injured chris
and they're claiming he's not injured
and there's a sense out there that he is
well i mean you know i'm gonna take his
word for it i'm gonna just go by what i
see on the football field i mean we saw
him move around and scramble a little
last night you know is he a hundred
percent there
you know i don't know but it's not so
much where it's like i don't know
popping out to you or me who are
obsessed with football we both are we
watch it all the time i don't look at
him go right now and go oh there's
something not right or his throwing
motion doesn't look normal or the ball
is not popping out of his hands listen
it's a systemic problem you know they've
they they can't run the ball you know so
there's that issue okay now they they're
they're they're dropping balls left and
right you know so he starts to lose
confidence and what guy do i trust do i
really want to throw to this receiver
the offense has become very predictable
as we know like we said like we were
talking about last night it's become
predictable in its predictability hey
we're going to throw it every play and
we're also going to throw it right here
in this area every play so that's tough
to get any mojo going defenses the
bangles last night you saw them i mean
they were playing downhill it's like
they felt very confident what they were
seeing and what the plays were being
thrown at them and all that that allowed
them to play aggressive and fast and you
know i just think with all those issues
it's it's kind of funneled out of
control right now and they aren't a funk
and that's why i was surprised when they
threw that touchdown pass i thought that
might snap them out of the funk to where
you know here he goes he might get a
little confidence back but you know that
that wasn't long lived the bengals kind
of smushed that pretty quickly
here's the sad reality if he's not
injured and my point is he's not injured
and if he is injured the steelers are
running a risk of getting whacked at
some point because there will be records
of the treatment he's receiving for his
injury two straight weeks not on the
injury report i'll take his word for it
i'll take their word for it because
there may be records that would dispute
them and i don't think they're dumb
enough to allow that to happen so
if he's not injured
he's just bad there's no good
alternative here you almost would rather
be injured no he's not injured he's old
and he's not as good as he used to be
sure this isn't one specific trauma that
he has endured that is causing him to be
limited in some way this is an
accumulation of years and years and
years of football and this was my
concern last year with the elbow injury
that this is just the beginning of
things to come because he's pushing 40
and he's been beaten around for his
entire career because he embraced it for
his entire career this is like cam
newton at age 38 even though
ben didn't have the same degree of
injuries count newton's
same idea big strong guy who gets hit by
everyone and keeps going right at some
point you know what you just can't do it
anymore and we may be reaching the point
where ben rothersberger just can't do it
anymore
physically so
he'd be better off saying he's injured
than saying well i don't know what it is
well what it is is you're 38 and here's
the contrast yeah he's 38 ryan finley's
25 we were marveling at ryan finley's
ability to keep going last night after
he got blown up by a hit that hurt the
defender how many times has he had
quarterback get hit and the defender is
the one who's injured not ryan finley
well ryan finley was moving around like
he's made out of that stuff they found
at area 51 that they make the flying
saucers out of that's unbreakable he's
like completely composed of that because
he's 25. was he that's why and then then
i couldn't tell is he smiling is he
grimacing is he happy isn't he sad all
night long i was like i can't tell what
the hell this guy is doing but when when
you're 25 now i i submit to you that
that guy's not getting out of bed until
friday once it all kind of hit the
adrenaline wears off and and it and it
kind of soaks in what he's been through
and he's going to be in worse shape at
38 if he keeps taking hits like that but
he's 25 he's young and he can deal with
it the composition of his body allows
him to deal with it it's that simple ben
is
to borrow a line that we use from time
to time but we stopped short of saying
the last word he is getting too old for
this
stuff well period yeah period mike and
too old for this stuff like you know you
you said it right
he's played a really physical brand of
football for a quarterback i mean he
really did it's going to catch up he's
not going to be able to be i don't think
drew brees or tom brady you know because
they they played in different offenses
you know we've talked about it for years
big ben had some of the worst pass
protection of football and they still
sat in the pocket and threw the ball and
he patted the ball seven times and just
got crushed and killed and you know ran
around the pocket like he was so great
at and still made plays that all of that
was amazing the biggest issue is like
yes of course the players decline you
know he's not going to be able to carry
the football team anymore but the crazy
thing is that's how they play
they're playing like hey big ben carry
us every week let's get in the shotgun
let you throw it all around and just
carry the squad
he's not capable of doing that that's
why they've got to find more ways it was
encouraging they got the run game going
last night maybe they can maybe they can
build off that and at least just get
some semblance to have some play action
make some defenses think of different
things but you're right mike you know i
still think they can win with big ben
but at 38 shotgun we're going to throw
it 50 times a game every play you're not
going to win that way look at this
sprite chart here you know again we talk
about the predictability of the offense
just look at everything everything is
you know 10 yards
10 yards or under on the inside edge of
the numbers it's all condensed in there
we saw one touchdown pass down the right
sideline right other than that you
really didn't see a whole lot so you
know that that's not a formula for a 38
year old quarterback who can't run and
extend plays anymore for them to win
football games that way and it's coming
back to bite them in the butt now
they're still out of whack in the run
past balance although they've running
more at least they did last night 18
carries for 84 yards for benny snell and
he summed it up very simply why was the
offense better last night because they
ran it more period now they got to get
rid of the jet sweep the jet sweeps not
working they smoked that thing out i
don't know if it's a formational thing i
don't know what it is but i haven't seen
them pop a jet sweep at all well there's
nothing else that's scary
well you're right like when they see
motion right now you just go be ready
for the jet sweep what what else it's
the only time they send motion sometimes
and do stuff like that so that it's it's
backed into the predictability thing
there's just not enough off of enough
right now you know you know plays that
start off looking the same but end up
being different i don't see that i just
see shotgun we're gonna throw it and be
quick and you know be surgical at all
that and between the drops and big ben
not playing as well and then playing
some defenses that understand them
that's it that's an issue and you know
mike last thing just with the you you
brought up the finley thing
you know that's also concerning to me
with the steelers too
i mean i don't know am i crazy like i
feel like if joe burrow played last
night the bengals win by
they win by 28. i mean ryan finley
missed some throws in the second half
where you go
these guys are gonna it's gonna be a
50-yard gain this might be a touchdown
and he missed those throws you know so
that's concerning about the steelers
defense too to where i go if that was a
real solid backup quarterback or starter
right there they would have got carved
up a little last night too with some of
those plays so it's it's the whole squad
right now to be concerned with in
pittsburgh and i'm going to be
interested to see if they can get this
you know the the ship righted here the
last two weeks of the year
finland finley thank you for saying ship
finley said or finley said finley ran it
10 times last night and only threw 13
passes the the for his out of whack as
the steelers were toward the pass the
bengals ran it 41 times and threw it at
13. where'd it go look it it and it
worked yeah it worked uh
that's the bottom line whether it was
ryan finley brandon allen whoever it was
they made it work and that was a
signature victory for a bengals team
that's trying to lay the foundation for
something for next year and look they
may need ryan finley or brandon allen or
someone else in the early part of the
year because of the extent of the knee
injury that joe burrows suffered so
they're trying to build something and
that was positive they need to put that
in a bottle and and hold on to it and
figure out how to make that happen
next year maybe they want to play the
steelers week one and have juju dance on
the logo again so whatever it was it it
was effective for once two ten and one
cincinnati bengals and hey
look they're kind of caught in that
weird spot where they're in no position
not that they number one need
trevor lawrence or justin fields they've
got joe burrow and number two they're
not going to sink low enough to get in
the top two spots so
that whole concept of whether or not
they should have tried to lose nothing i
think it was better for that franchise
right now where they are established to
throw a wrench into the gear for the
steelers the steelers have been the
bullies of that division
forever and between the ravens the
bengals and the browns now they have got
their hands full and
we mentioned ben roethlisberger's age
this is a point that we made earlier
this year when things were going well
for the steelers now that they're not
going well it becomes more pronounced
they better have a post ben plan at
quarterback where they are going to be
the third or fourth place team in that
division every year they got a way
without
having
a franchise quarterback for 20 years
from terry bradshaw to ben rothersburg
it was a revolving door of mediocrity
with flashes flashes like cordell
stewart yeah flashes
good right but it would but it would
eventually regress they got away with
that because their defense was so damn
good they better have a plan for getting
their next quarterback or they are going
to be left by the wayside in the afc
north chris no well i mean agreed agreed
they they got to think about it because
you know like you said this is big ben
at 38 we don't think it's going to last
forever and
the afc north's got some young studs
i mean across the board forget the
quarterbacks just you know teams in
general
there's a lot of young good football
players that where you go
man the future in cleveland the future
in cincinnati i mean you see t higgins
and what he's doing last night william
jackson at corner you know covering
people doing that you know there's a lot
of good players in the afc north you
know the guys on the broadcast last
night they brought it up i don't know
mike afc north is it the best division
in football right now i mean you got
three playoff teams sitting in there
right now i know the ravens are just on
the outside sitting in but uh i think
it's a very good question i probably i
think it's probably real i don't know
they probably are the best division in
football right now
it's afc north versus nfc west i think
we had that debate earlier this year
shereen williams and i were arguing
about it and i think she said the afc
north i think and you know what right
now yes the afc north and when you
consider the team playing the worst
right now
right now is the steelers that's a
pretty damn good division but they are
guaranteed their playoff spot the
question is where will they be will it
be three four five or six
we'll find out over the course of the
next 12 days it adds some entry and
spice to the final days of the regular
season and adding some intriguing spice
to the offseason chris i know ben
roethlisberger has said he plans to play
multiple additional years he said before
the season he's interested in winning
lombardi's with an s yeah he's got two
he wants at least two more
he's got a real question
that will be confronting him in the
offseason he's gonna have to ask himself
can i still do this is it an age thing
and is it gonna be any better a year
from now spoiler alert it's not it ain't
going to be any better and there's a
chance it's going to be worse he has a
cap number next year
in the final year of his current deal of
41.25 whoa are you kidding me whoa 41.25
million he makes 19 million so if he
would retire he still leaves behind 22
million yeah if they're gonna keep him
they have to extend the contract it's
that drew brees thing where you keep
pushing the reckoning under the cap out
to that first year without brees
whenever it may be the steelers are now
going to be in that mode there's going
to be a reckoning the first year after
ben it's going to be 22 million if next
year is
the year that he says see you later uh
and if he comes back and doesn't want to
sign a contract doesn't want to extend
his contract they're stuck with 41
million under the cap for ben next year
and right now based on how he's playing
he's not gonna have a plan b one million
dollars but i have a plan b that's for
sure i think you said that you gotta
have a plan b you gotta have something
there because you you look at him in 38
and look at you know like tom at 43 i
still think big ben's got another year
or two left in him i do but i don't
think they can play the way they're
playing that has to be readjusted and
then you look at him compared to brady
brady looks like a spring chicken
compared to the big ben right now the
way he's moving around and hopping and
how fresh his arm looks and all of that
you know so you know to your point that
you brought up earlier you know in the
show already that you know i just think
the accumulation of wear and tear and
everything and big ben not exactly being
tb 12 all off season and all that is is
finally catching up a little bit and uh
yeah we're seeing it on the field but i
don't think it's over yet i'm not going
to count them out quite yet
the the big ben camp doesn't like
that comment but the eyeball test
is is the prevailing standard it's clear
that big ben is not on the tb12 plan and
he's never been and apart from any hits
you take and here's where i
here's where i tried out my my uh md
that i that i don't own and oh please
let me hear that qualify down no it's
just the idea of the wear and tear from
the fact that you're that big
just
regardless of whether or not you're hit
when you're carrying that much weight on
your body it's going to put extra stress
on all the things that at age 38 39 40
are going to start feeling the effects
of it just from carrying that very large
body around all these years on a
football field it's we're seeing it
happen no you're what are they going to
do about it are they going to get rid of
randy fitner the offensive coordinator
and you know there's a segment of
steelers fans that they they activate
every year there's like a bat signal
they activate oh i just say fire my
tommen which is ludicrous it's ludicrous
but you're going to hear that if they
lose this week and if they end up losing
the division the anti-mike tomlin crowd
there are people in ownership the
minority owners that there have been
movements in the past to get rid of mike
tomlin art rooney ignores them but there
is a segment of the fan base as dumb as
it is that we'll rise up and say we need
a new coach
you're right every year we hear it but
that's done i mean that you know be
quiet i don't know what else to say
there i mean i want to say something way
more harsh but when you're 11 when
you're 11 and oh they are quiet yeah
well yeah you're welcome three straight
losses they're going to wake up well
yeah in fact in my life it was the
opposite when they were 11-0 and i
didn't put big ben in my top 10
quarterbacks through the first you know
10 weeks of the year oh my gosh i mean
they they the the the the steelers mafia
assembled and that's all i heard for
like two weeks but i haven't heard from
them in the last few weeks mike oddly
enough but mike tomlin being fired on a
hot seat is insane insane i mean that's
insane he's one of the best coaches in
football and what he's done there is
amazing and i don't think that's going
to gain any steam even from those crazy
steelers fans that try to start that
this year
you know and this is a historic collapse
there's never been a team that started
11-0 that didn't win its division we
mentioned the jets who were eight and
three in 2008 brett favre's only year
with the team that fell apart down the
stretch because of that partially torn
biceps tendon they eventually had
surgically torn so he could play in
minnesota yeah 1986 jets started 10-0
right remember and it fell apart did
they not even make the playoffs they
lost to the browns in the double
overtime 23-20 game the week before
cleveland lost to elway in the drive
right so that was that little thing
there but yeah at one point
in new york that year the giants were
like you know eight and two and the the
jets were 10-0 it was pretty
unbelievable
yeah well 2008 the same deal the giants
had one loss going into late november
the plexico burris thing happened yadda
yadda they didn't get past the
divisional round and the jets didn't
even get to the playoffs in 2008 so uh
steelers for having such a historic
start to the season be careful what you
wish for it sets the stage potentially
for historic collapse
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports